le modèle néerlandais place les
infirmiers et infirmières au centre du
système et les médecins du public y
participent également le recours au
centre de soins pour personnes
âgées ne se fait que dans les cas
extrêmes un système à l'opposé de
l'approche québécoise aujourd'hui en
campagne électorale les partis
politiques se disent tous en parfait
accord avec la proche des Pays-Bas les
Pays-Bas ça fait si vous regardez dans
nos propositions de novembre 2021 dans
notre plateforme électorale c'est un
modèle qui revient constamment c'est un
modèle qui est important mais c'est un
virage qu'il faut faire dès maintenant
qu'on propose de partir libérales du
Québec est similaire à ce modèle c'est
plus de soi au niveau à domicile nous
évidemment au Parti québécois ça nous
fait plaisir de voir que ce modèle là
est un exemple puisque c'est exactement
ce qu'on propose au Québec lors de la
campagne électorale de son côté la CAC a
décliné notre demande d'entrevue et nous
a plutôt fait parvenir une réponse
écrite dans laquelle elle nous dit nous
allons investir 900 millions pour
répondre aux souhaits des personnes
âgées de demeurer à domicile le plus
longtemps possible et elle ajoute nous
avons donné un mandat à la Commissaire à
la santé au bien-être afin d'optimiser
nos pratiques en soins à domicile
et donc tout le monde est pour les soins
à domicile au Québec et pourtant ça se
fait très peu pourquoi
hospitalistes
d'exception au Québec elle travaille en
soins à domicile dans la région de
Montréal depuis 40 ans et elle déplore
l'approche du gouvernement actuel et de
la Fédération des médecins
omnipraticiens qui privilégie les soins
en institution les médecins famille au
Québec remplacent beaucoup les médecins
spécialistes dans certaines unités
d'hospitalisation en milieu urbain ce
qui nous enlève environ 1500 équivalents
temps plein médecin en première ligne
c'est dommage parce que justement on a
besoin de ces 1500 médecins là à
domicile les parties d'opposition
s'entendent pour dire que les médecins
doivent faire preuve de plus de
souplesse dans leur pratique l'objectif
c'est d'aider la population c'est
d'aller où est-ce qu'il y a des besoins
moi en étant omnipratien je suis pas
spécialisé le très spécialisé dans rien
mais je suis capable de
la fiabilité et la plupart des
omnipraticiens au Québec ont cette
capacité là à aller avoir une
versatilité dans la façon de pratiquer
un Québec solidaire on souhaite aussi le
financement des soins à domicile à
raison de 750 millions de dollars par an
il va falloir qu'on mette le bien commun
avant tout avant le corporatif
professionnel ce qu'il faut qu'on se
demande c'est comment collectivement
tout le monde ensemble on est capable de
relever le défi du vieillissement de la
population c'est le Parti québécois qui
remporte la palme des dépenses projetées
pour des soins à domicile soit 3
milliards de plus par an pendant 5 ans
les infirmières les infirmiers là leur
bienveillance puis leur sens du service
public on va faire en sorte qu'ils vont
vouloir visiter les gens à domicile
enfin le Parti libéral prévoit de
faibles hausses de budget soit 26
millions par an pour les soins de
missiles des aînés premièrement mettre
l'argent nécessaire avoir plus
d'infirmières en soins à domicile ne pas
oublier que si le modèle du Pays-Bas
fonctionne c'est que le médecin il est
là la solution québécoise pour offrir de
meilleurs soins à domicile et peut-être
plus simple qu'on ne le croit nous dit
cette médecin est-ce qu'on peut au lieu
de toujours réinventer des nouvelles
structures faire en sorte qu'on utilise
les excellents services à domicile des
céleste et juste d'y adjoindre les
équipes médicales et le tour est réglé
Sylvain Desjardins Radio-Canada Montréal